دعني أسألك عن التكنولوجيا لأن
أحد المجالات التي يقلق
الناس من دخولها هو نوع من
الحرب الباردة التكنولوجية
أو فصل حيث ينتهي بنا الأمر
بمنطقة تكنولوجيا صينية
وأخرى غير صينية أو غربية أو أمريكية
ليست كذلك.  من العدل أن نقول إن جزءًا من هذا
قد حدث ،
لأن الصين
كانت بالفعل هي التي بدأت هذه العملية من خلال
حظر معظم شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى في أمريكا
من المشاركة في الصين ، أفكر
في google facebook ،
فلا يوجد أي شيء تقريبًا في أمريكا
شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى في الصين
، وبدلاً من الانفتاح بمرور الوقت على
التحرير بمرور الوقت كما توقع الناس ،
أعتقد
في الواقع أن القواعد أصبحت أكثر تقييدًا
في هذا المجال ،
أعتقد أن كل هذه الشركات أكثر دقة ،
ما يريدون
هو حصة سوقية كبيرة  في الصين ،
لا أعتقد أن هدفهم هو مشاركة
التكنولوجيا مع الصين ،
فهم يريدون فقط كسب المال في
السوق الصينية
بالطبع يمكنهم القدوم ونحن
منفتحون على  جميع الشركات الأمريكية
ولكن هناك قيود حالية بل ومتصاعدة
تفرضها حكومة الولايات المتحدة
ضد
كل هذا التدفق للتكنولوجيا ، التدفق الحر
للتكنولوجيا والمعلومات ، كان
هذا هو الحال
لسنوات عديدة ، لكن على وجه الخصوص في
السنوات القليلة الماضية ،
أعتقد أن التقدم التكنولوجي يجب أن
يستفيد
الجميع من ذلك في المجتمع العالمي بأسره
والجميع في أي مجتمع ولكن
تم تسييس هذه القضية إلى حد كبير
وهذا أمر مؤسف للغاية